depuis le 17 mars la france est mise
sous cloche un confinement qui va durer
a déjà prévenu l'elysée qui pour de
nombreux étudiants a des conséquences
très difficile certains sont
complètement isolés obligé de rester sur
les campus universitaires
les initiatives se multiplient à travers
tout le pays pour leur venir en aide
reportage à lyon avec un louis carvalho
et repas fut elle comme tous les matins
depuis le 26 mars
catherine fillon professeur d'histoire
du droit à l'université lyon iii
réceptionne une livraison de produits
frais tels les paniers de fruits et de
légumes pour les étudiants qui arrivent
et si les commandants grossi de carottes
de pommes de terre de bananes et
d'orange
al'annonce du confinement de la
population cette enseignante à créer en
urgence le collectif de solidarité
étudiante
objectif offrir une aide matérielle et
alimentaires aux étudiants restés
confinés à lyon fermeture des
restaurants universitaires pertes
d'emplois baisse du montant des bourses
depuis le début de la crise du
coronavirus nombre d'entre eux se
retrouvent en situation d'extrême
précarité
on a aussi beaucoup d'étudiants
brésilien qui est l art en situation des
changes qui aujourd'hui sont très très
grande difficulté financière
parce que apparemment bas la monnaie
s'est effondré
il ya d autres ans qui ne sont pas du
tout en leur faveur et leurs bourses qui
était financée par le brésil ne vaut
plus rien je vois bien que mes étudiants
en galère je m'en rends compte au jour
le jour et j'ai bien compris que dans
cette situation exceptionnelle il allait
perdre il allait perdre une partie
importante des revenus qui va permettre
de survivre dans bien des cas je n'ai
même pas de vivre et de survivre 80
volontaires se relaient quotidiennement
pour livrer de la nourriture des
produits d'hygiène mais aussi des
conseils médicaux car aux carences
matériel il faut ajouter les problèmes
d'ordre psychologique provoquée par
cette situation inédite en partenariat
avec le collectif une cellule de
psychologues propose des entretiens aux
multiples étudiants qui vivent mal le
confinement
on prend contact avec eux
psychologiquement et on se rend compte
que c'est extrêmement important
ils ont besoin de reprendre lien avec le
monde extérieur on a des psychologues
qui nous propose bénévolement leur aide
pour les étudiants qui sont vraiment en
très très grande difficulté
psychologique et qu'il exprime de façon
générale c'est simplement le fait de
reprendre de reprendre lien avec le
monde extérieur et se rend compte qu'il
ya des gens qui qui se préoccupent de
qui leur fait immédiatement le plus
grand bien pour beaucoup c'est tout
simplement ça ça suffit a remonté le
moral
inspirée d'une initiative pionnière
menée sur le campus de bordeaux
le collectif de solidarité étudiante mis
sur la générosité environ 14000 euros de
dons ont été récoltés en moins d'une
semaine afin d'acheter des produits de
première nécessité